going back to the being the politician
analogy which i think is just brilliant
so many filmmakers sometimes seem like
they get a little nervous being in front
of the crowd whereas the actors love it
and I know there will be people in
groups you know if you ever watched like
the Jerry Springer Show
whatever they love to test that person
in the hot seat and they like to kind of
see the reaction so sometimes people
stand up curious why you did this
BAM silence you're on so how would you
advise the more shy reclusive auteur to
handle that situation because it
inevitably will happen it does you ask
you basically you have to man up in
those situations and you have to sort of
you have to just be kind and remember
things from their point of view I mean
you start attacking the audience you
know it's not cool no one in the are
even your your your allies answer my god
man you know we had a thing at the QA
for favor the very first the very first
world premiere it was a really good Q&A
but we have one guy in the audience they
start talking about Mad Men because in
favor blame Weaver's character it works
for an ad agency and I I had worked in
advertising and you know there was a
creative pitch I mean there's the nice
board remember he gets dressed up of me
to a client but for the most part these
scruffy little hold ends with like you
know deaths covered in papers and bits
of product and and just do some notes
and cartoons and just weird stuff
everybody's like you know got their
sleeves rolled up in they're not
bouncing a ball against the wall it's a
very messy kind of low-key low-rent
environment so in the film we shot it
that way I mean part of it was because
we didn't have we couldn't afford you
big ass offices but but we shot the way
I
I know it you know which is a scruffy
little you know work pit and the guy the
guy is all this older gentleman from the
audience started going well you know
because I went for several minutes you
guys you know seeing this low-rent
scuzzy a dude's in his film makes me
wonder why you chose do that because
most of us are just seeing what Angie's
looking
AMC's Mad Men new season which is
debuting and June 5th or something like
that II you know those rooms are
pristine I'm just seeing these scuzzy
scumbags Skid Row looking he went on and
finally and he kept saying maybe AMC's
Mad Men and I finally said you sure do
you work for AMC I said well I work in
advertising this is what I'm used to I
know that I'm I'm sorry their reality of
your 1960s soap opera it doesn't quite
add up to you know this this is not
AMC's Mad Men there's no Dondre pretty
yeah that guys note he say called Blaine
Weaver no Don Draper so we're just kind
of like we're kind of like well I know
it's a good show you know that's a great
you just kind of like you kind of
justify your choice and the guys are you
say well you know yeah it's a great show
and you kind of find something in his
opinion or that person's opinion - I can
see I can see why you would say that hmm
or I can I see I see your point of view
you know step into their shoes for a
moment and sort of see you from there so
or at least say you can and I think
often if someone does have an axe to
grind which again does not happen very
often but if someone does have an axe to
grind they're confused about something
in the film and they see something
negative or or murky hearing them out
and not belittling them treating them
like they're stupid or just puny with
respect regardless of what they're
saying I think they're gonna be come
away feeling better about it
I was heard and they're gonna still
leave your screening happy and satisfied
weld I didn't really was okay but I like
the guy you know or
maybe they'll go yeah you know that was
pretty good you know yeah there's one
thing that I wish had been different
wasn't what I was expecting but you know
they come away feeling better
one of the worst Q&A I felt so bad was
for a film called coffee kill boss which
is the opening night film in Austin last
year and I know I know a couple of the
cast members and the movies not
confusing at all I mean it's a comedy
and it's not anything what happens in
the film and I don't know why this
happened but at the qat someone in the
audience said so who was the killer I
was like super like it was
it was like a major reveal who the
killer was you're the killer I mean like
it was super obvious and the director
goes it was so and so so and so was the
killer well wait when who was well I
thought so I was the killer and someone
who obviously wasn't the killer no no it
was it was so and so what did so-and-so
survive well we saw them dead in that
scene with the knife and so that would
like it like it was like seven or eight
questions deep of people like asking him
story points that were painfully obvious
and I saw him afterwards and I said
don't worry don't worry
it's the film's not confusing at all
like I don't know why you had this run
of people who didn't follow the movie
but I can't imagine why anybody would be
confused you didn't make a confusing
film because for him it must have been
like oh my god what have I done like no
one can follow this movie you know well
sometimes there's on public contrarians
that like to kind of be the one that
stands up yes whether it's in a
classroom or a work they loved and I
think the way to defuse those people is
agree with everything they're saying
because that actually diffuses a little
bit their whole purpose I think you
shouldn't keep mind you are different or
in front of an audience when this is
happening it's not like a one-to-one I
think above you afterwards you still be
respectful but when you're in front of a
lot of other people you do up to mean
it's it's Obama at a town hall meeting
you got to you got to take down that one
that one really conservative Tea Party
person says well I don't like this and
you gotta kind of well actually I
understand your point of view I
understand this well you have to kind of
diffuse it but what I find often happens
almost always happens is again your QA
is your barometer of how the audience
has reacted so if you lose most people
for your Q&A and there's no reason to
like it's not because your screen name
is running late or there's something
else happening that they have to get to
normally if you lose most of your
audience it's because they didn't like
the song it was half your audience you
divided the audience but half liked it
Hatton liked it it's a cult them but
people that stay or want to stay because
they enjoyed the movie and they want to
talk to you and find out something about
it if you do like a film you know one
about it so almost everybody in your
audience that stays is on your side with
favor we had really good retention the
fact thank God we had like 90 95 percent
people would consistently would stick
around for the Q&A so we were doing
pretty well and that said most q and A's
most of the people are almost almost
every q Nate everybody's cool because
again they all like the movie but every
once in a while every five or six q and
A's is that one detractor stands up and
universally almost every time you have
to do anything because the other
audience members will jump on him what
do you mean you know like oh I thought
it was too long we was a perfect length
what was too long what would you cut out
what would you kind of like it was you
know like they there's always that way
they stand up and sort of defend you you
know it's sort of interesting and again
so it makes it way easier to be like the
cool guy in the room right because they
don't have to prove anything anybody
here you're angry you're angry mob of
fans just you know they don't have to
make fun of this guy but you still kind
of want to another everybody can like
your movie you know just just the way it
is you can't there's nothing wrong with
someone who doesn't like your film and
just not their cup of tea whatever it is
so you have to be prepared for that and
respectful of it and hear them out
sometimes you'll learn more from those
that didn't like you than those that did
you